ein jahr besonders dramatischer appell
vorschlag der kommt von professor
henning stellvertretender vorsitzenden
des deutschen ethikrats ich will das
zitat einmal vorlesen guten abend
gesehen und schon trotzdem einmal noch
vorweg wer eine impfung verweigert der
solle doch bitte selbst von einer
beatmung im krankheitsfall zurücktreten
haben sie gesagt erklären sie uns aber
ganz kurz was meinen sie damit
das handeln konsequenzen hat und nicht
handeln hat auch konsequenzen und wer
sich aus der verantwortung herausziehen
will wasch mir den pelz aber mach mich
nicht nass
das sollte das auch wirklich dann mit
sich tragen das verständlich ist eine
solche patientenverfügung nicht
rechtlich binden aber sie sollte eine
dauerhafte erinnerung an leute sein die
sich auf kosten anderer leute aushalten
wollen aus dem durchaus kleinen
problemen der impfung was sie da
anrichten
glauben sie dass das gesellschaftlich
durchsetzbar wäre dass die mehrheit der
menschen zu ja für so eine erklärung
bereit wäre ein sicherlich nicht also
sage es ganz offen es ist natürlich
jetzt ein kein politisches ziel und
schon garnicht des ethikrats dem ganzen
privatmeinung von ihr dass man wirklich
da die karten auf den tisch legen soll
man muss seine überlegungen auch zu ende
denken die impfgegner sagen ja auch was
sie nicht wollen aber sie sagen nicht
was sie stattdessen wollen und wer keine
alternativen und keine argumente hat
dann muss auch wirklich dann mit der
nase darauf gestoßen werden das versuche
ich mir zu tun
wie erklären sie sich dass jetzt
mittlerweile nicht mehr die hälfte der
deutschen sich impfen lassen wollen laut
neueste umfragen
das ist immer im leben so vertrauen zu
zerstören ist sehr viel leichter als
vertrauen aufzubauen und da müssen wir
ganz behutsam rangehen klar ist und
bleibt eine allgemeine impfpflicht darf
es wird es nicht geben
und was können wir tun wir können erst
einmal als wissenschaftlerin als ärzte
im guten beispiel sein also uns selbst
das nicht selber wird mich am ersten tag
impfen lassen an dem ihr der impfstoff
zukommt und dass nach 30 jahren
genetiker erfahrung
wir müssen falschinformationen entgegen
wirken also solche sprüche wie der erna
impfstoff verändert eure gegner
völliger blödsinn von leuten verbreitet
die eben mit dem internet ihrer
megaphone haben aber die fakten sprechen
eine völlig andere sprache
das ist alles mühsam aber ich glaube
schon dass wir mit gutem beispiel ihr
durchkommen und wenn die leute die
burgen erfahrung haben die oma ist die
importe als gut überstanden so wird es
sein
dann bin ich auch ziemlich
zuversichtlich dass die akzeptanz auch
zunehmende professor händler müssen
wahrscheinlich noch ein unterschied
machen zwischen denjenigen die jetzt
etwas bedenken bei dem impfstoff haben
generell keine impfgegner sind und all
denjenigen die dort
verschwörungstheorien wie sie es gerade
angesprochen haben verbreiten und genau
deswegen wollen wir noch jemanden ihnen
dieses gespräche dazu einladen bei uns
im studio ist jetzt unsere kollegin
theresa müller theresa lässt sich
normalerweise immer impfen hat für uns
für bild auch eine dokumentation über
impfgegner gemacht aber sagt jetzt
erstmal abwarten theresa was genau sind
deine gründe warum du dich jetzt nicht
gleich anstellen wirst wenn die impfung
dann für uns alle verfügbar sind
also mein erstes problem mit der ganzen
geschichte ist diese diese sache mit den
langzeitfolgen also es gibt einfach
keine langzeitstudien dazu die werden
nicht gemacht und es hat natürlich ein
grund dass bei impfstoffen
langzeitstudien gemacht werden
also ist es mir da so ein bisschen so
ein punkt wohl sagen wenn ich nicht ganz
so cool
der zweite punkt ist einfach diese
rasante zeit in der wir diesen impfstoff
produziert haben klar für eine impfung
also beziehungsweise grippeimpfungen das
passiert jedes jahr ist jedes jahr eine
neue grippe also ist es auch jedes jahr
neue impfstoff aber andere impfstoffe
also diese kinder impfstoffe zum
beispiel das dauert teilweise jahrzehnte
bis die halt einfach fertig sind und
deswegen ist mir diese zeit jetzt so ein
bisschen skurril also
ich muss dazu betont ich bin absolut
kein impfgegner ganz im gegenteil
und ich halte nichts von
verschwörungstheoretikern und diese
ganzen leute die im internet ihren
würmer verbreiten aber da ist jetzt
gerade
ich habe einfach zu viele fragen die ich
auch einfach nicht beantwortet bekommen
herr professor
vielleicht können wir da direkt darauf
eingehen die schnelle entwicklung des
impfstoffs was sagen sie dazu sollte
unser skeptisch machen oder wie sehen
sie das
alles im leben ist eine frage der
alternativen können einfach nicht zehn
jahre warten bis wir langzeitstudien
haben aber wir haben umfangreiche
erfahrung mit impfungen gegen
vergleichbare erreger und insbesondere
haben wir das entwicklungs und
zulassungsverfahren oder kompromisse mit
der qualität schneller vorangetrieben
ganz simpel wenn man einen
konventionellen impfstoff ohne den druck
einer pandemie entwickelt hat man konnte
man meinen segen für 40.000 probanden
die man braucht für die entwicklung und
zulassung konnte man 4000 pro jahr
impfen 110 jahre sich zeit nehmen
diese zeit hatten wir diesmal nicht und
deshalb hat man unter anderem mit
hunderten von millionen staatsgeldern
aus deutschland die gut angelegt waren
eben dann 40.000 leute in einem halben
jahr geht das war eine riesen aktion
aber damit sind wir ohne kompromisse bei
der sicherheit einfach schneller gewesen
und das ist eine ganz große leistung das
sollte auch genug vertrauen schaffen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren